il ne bat pas le pavé pour la fête des
lumières mais pour exprimer leur colère
une centaine de personnes se sont
réunies sur la place bellecour à lyon
pour soutenir les commerçants touchés de
plein fouet par les mesures restrictives
duo kobe 19
objectif demander la réouverture des
restaurants dès le 15 décembre date
prévue pour la fin du confinement
les manifestants réclament également
l'indemnisation des pertes
d'exploitation par les assurances
la prise en charge des loyers ou encore
la modification du statut d'indépendant
au niveau des hôteliers on a en a eu
quelques-uns effectivement qui sont
améliorées mais au niveau des assurances
est toujours un scandale puisque j'ai
été indemnisés pour la première partie
et la maaf elle refuse de payer d'aidé
pour la deuxième partie en prétextant
d'autres articles qui n'existait pas
dans la première
tout pour se mobiliser tous ensemble et
métiers de l'événementiel de
l'hôtellerie
ce rang les experts en service les
cuisiniers des étudiants aussi con plus
de stages et petits boulots
très important
son ensemble
on demande pour toutes les raisons
évoquées pendant le discours à rouvrir
les restaurants le 15 décembre
pin pour que les gens commencent à
revivre quand on a des protocoles
sanitaires et pour que la vie revienne
dans nos stations de ski dans nos villes
solidaires également avec les stations
de ski dont les remontées mécaniques
sont fermées jusqu'à l'année prochaine
pour leur rendre hommage les
participants étaient invités à
s'habiller en bleu en blanc ou en rouge
et à celui d'hier d'un bonnet dans une
ambiance festive et musicale plusieurs
chars ont déambulé dans les rues
le rassemblement s'est achevé avec un
lâcher de lanternes symbolique afin de
revoir de la lumière sur lyon lumières
éteintes depuis trop longtemps pour ces
commerçants